j'aimerais vous présenter quelqu'un elle
s'appelle adèle s cadel peut venir
m
oh
alors que la présente aux
téléspectateurs adel c'est une jeune
fille qui travaille avec nous et qui est
cadreuse pour l'émission caméra van cau
mon niveau cadre us caméra one
ça fait comme un temps où travaillent
ensemble sur sept ans est hanté road
avec moi très beau si je t'adore et je
dois toujours te must voit toujours
tomari derrière la caméra c'est ça tous
les soirs c'est quoi lorsque je sais que
tu m'as parlé d'un truc et j'aimerais
que tu lui parles tu en parles à
l'antenne soit tu as envie de faire un
truc c'est quoi ton rêve
mon rêve c'est de participer à un raid
au vietnam
ouais qui s'appelle le raid amazones
avec ma cuisine en fait on a pour projet
et ses camps parce que tu travailles
avait peut être nous allons passer ça
c'est comme un temps ses dix jours dix
jours quant au mois d'octobre au mois
d'octobre
ça m'arrange pas et je sais que c'est
ton rêve ma chérie et ce soir je sais
que voilà ça sert si c'est pas du tout
et bah écoute moi bien j'ai pris une
grande décision cette nuit j'ai pensé à
toi ma chérie tu vas le faire ce raid
alors elle va faire ce raid est comme ça
elle va arrêter de nous faire chier
c'est à oui elle est très jolie elle
était vraiment cc oui à propos de vous
faire chier alors vous justement bouger
un autre truc je le dis vous on va vous
allez avoir aussi du raid salé pour les
moustiques sont maintenant vides et moi
c'est le glamour par rapport aux fans
mais à propos de faire chier j se peut
que je fasse une petite pause il fait
très chaud je transpire beaucoup et
depuis les douaniers sont au péage
l'avions fait au guichet
[Applaudissements]
les petits pâtés finale qu'on appelle
samba alors winch en fait on reste
revenir les choses non on reste folie on
reste poli et c'est bien une personne
d'un certain âge parce que chez
certaines personnes dont ce type est
donc ça concerne pas donc éviter de
toucher vos petits camarades il avait
caché des membres si jamais je m'en vais
vous ne m'en voulez pas alors sur le jeu
rapidement oui juste je vous le dis
alors ce soir et je vous le dis si on
prenait quelque chose dans la gueule
sera pas du chocolat
[Applaudissements]
il n'y aura pas de chocolat ce soir
étant donné qu'on est déjà en danger des
personnes voilà d'où du chocolat